- So you still get a lot of fan mail.
So here's one that you posted.
- [Taylor Lautner] Oh boy.
- Let's show this.
- [Taylor Lautner] Oh.
(Kelly laughing)
Oh, yes.
- First of all, if you're
rockin' that kind of body,
boy, I'd be doin' those photos too.
(Taylor laughing)
Like, that's amazing!
- Here's my favorite
thing about that photo.
I'm not wearing anything-
- Except tennis shoes!
- But tennis shoes.
(audience members laughing)
Like, what? I don't-
- [Kelly Clarkson] Because you
wanna take care of your feet.
- [Taylor Lautner] Yeah.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- [Taylor Lautner] Yeah. I
guess. I guess. Love the shoes.
- This is amazing!
- [Taylor Lautner] Great touch.
- Oh my god. That's amazing!
Well, because of streaming,
everybody is starting
to rediscover things.
Like, there were huge pop culture moments.
- [Taylor Lautner] Yeah.
- And even my seven year
old daughter, literally,
I found her watching
Twilight which, I love you,
but I had to turn it
off 'cause she's seven.
- Yeah.
- But I love the movies and she's,
I'll let her watch 'em when she's older,
but it's cool because
you're getting these,
all these new audiences.
- [Taylor Lautner] Yeah.
- Like, and I think
that's kind of interesting
and I know that you had to have had
crazy passionate fans back in the day.
You're probably getting even more now.
What's like a crazy story
from like a fan that happened?
- They're definitely more chill
now because, like you said,
it's like, it's like these younger kids
that are coming up that
are just starting to watch-
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah!
- Twilight for the first time, but I mean,
back in the day there's, oh my gosh,
there's a list of just crazy memories and-
- [Kelly Clarkson] I can't imagine.
- Fan experiences-
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- From, you know, being in Brazil
and having thousands of
fans break into our hotel
and they had to call the
Brazilian National Guard
to get them out.
- What?
- These are very passionate fans.
I mean, it's why the books
and movies are so successful
is these fans.
They don't give up.
They get what they want.
- I love the books and movies.
I would never break into your hotel room.
There are normal fans.
(Kelly and Taylor laughing)
It's like, there are people
that just appreciate the art.
(Taylor chuckling)